et à présent un mot sur la mobilisation
contre la réforme des collèges dans
l'académie de versailles ses 4,8 pour
cent des enseignants qui étaient en
grève aujourd'hui un taux très en deçà
de la mobilisation des mois dernier les
enseignants répondaient à l'appel
une semaine après la rentrée de
l'intersyndicale du second degré alors
selon les chiffres communiqués par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale 4,6
pour cent des enseignants des collèges
publics et 1,1 pour cent des enseignants
des lycées été créé et est gréviste
aujourd'hui alors l'intersyndicale
constituée du snes fsu qui le premier
syndicat du secondaire du snep fsu fo
cgt sud et s'endettent a appelé à
manifester à paris au départ de la place
de la sorbonne
delphine roumanie secrétaire snes fsu
des yvelines y était je propose de
l'écouter nous l'avons joint par
téléphone
si une mobilisation c'est sûr on va
parce qu'acheter de chez pas énorme
c'est une mobilisation de rentrer donc
les collègues sont aussi d'entre eux
leur emploi du temps
la mise en place de leurs de leur vie
personnelle s'est confié pour se
mobiliser - ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que sur l'académie de versailles
c'est le point de départ de la
mobilisation de rente et de nous va
venir
des actions tout au long du mois de
septembre des assemblées générales avec
le collègue des réunions à destination
des parents d'élèves un stage qui sera
destiné à souder enseignants sera de la
formation syndicale sur la réponse du
collège donc voilà tout ça bien sûr
puisque nous notre mot d'ordre
aujourd'hui c'est l abrogation de la
réponse du collège